one down 99 more wells in Africa to go
you're going to love this video let's
move on cuz I wanted to hit something
that that's a little bit different uh in
terms of just sort of the chaos of the
last month but I thought also in sort of
opens the door to a lot of the internet
craziness we're dealing with and how
when even good people try to do good
things there is always a price to pay so
this guy Mr Beast uh who is Hu he might
be the is he the number one YouTuber at
this point he is the number one YouTuber
the guy's worth a gajillion dollars and
he takes his gajillion dollars and he
sees he tries to do a lot of good things
with his money so one thing that he was
trying to do uh or that he not only not
was just trying to do that he actually
did was build a hundred wells in Africa
so that African children could get fresh
water you might think that this is
pretty good uh here's a little bit of
the video uh when he uh when he did this
and then put it up this about a week ago
100 Wells we're going to build in this
video oh
water oh oh crap you just witnessed a
small village in Kenya get access to
unlimited clean drinking water in less
than a second one down 99 more wells in
Africa to go you're going to love this
video combined these 100 Wells are going
to give around half a million people
fresh water to drink and after building
some more Wells on this side of Kenya we
flew South to the school system of niri
and let's just say they were were really
happy to see us how's it going one of
the teachers showed me where the
students currently get their water which
is from this River that's extremely
unsafe to drink this where your students
used to get water from yes this is crazy
at least for this Village we're going to
put it into it right now I don't think
this John's going to
fit I have a big head let's see if we
can find some
water
it is raining it's
beautiful okay so obviously it goes on
I'm being told this guy has 209 million
subscribers I have never felt so
irrelevant in my life but he's doing
good work he obviously is earned them
and earned all the accolades and the
financial success and everything else
but anyway so he does this thing and uh
and of course there was going to be
Fallout so first let's look at his
original tweet on this thing he said we
built wells in Africa go watch and then
Ashley stclair who I've had on the show
Ashley said waiting for someone to call
this racist and then on Q here's Yahoo
news while American YouTuber Mr BEAST's
goal was to provide clean drinking water
for 500,000 people activists say his
actions shamed the Kenyon government and
helped perpetuate The Stereotype that
Africa is dependent on handouts uh this
eventually got hit with a community note
because this is now the factchecking
apparatus that uh you that Twitter has
uh brought in since Elon took over
readers added context they thought might
you might want to know this is relative
to the headline I just read the two
people deriding Mr Beast are one a
Kenyan politician and two a woman who
founded a 501c3 based in Cambridge
Massachusetts that raised 131,000 in
2020 and spent 83,000 on themselves so
all right
this happens with everything good people
try to do good things obviously the
Kenyan government is not doing
everything they can to get their own
people clean water he comes in and does
it a Kenyon government official is
pissed because it exposes him for being
a fraud and these nonprofit people that
basically do nothing also are not happy
because it shows that they don't do much
of anything Ian this is just Internet
101 right yeah yeah everything is racist
especially good things I mean I cannot
believe we can watch people who don't
have access to clean water getting clean
water Pres for free you know they're not
paying for this and people are upset
about that I can't believe we're talking
about this right now of all the
horrendous things that happen in the
world people are angry because a guy
decided to go to Africa and get water
for people it's unbelievable I do think
it's funny when politicians and um
people in American nonprofits get very
upset when someone just completely
supersedes them and actually goes and
does the thing they've been promising to
do uh politicians are notoriously inept
and the same is true for a lot of
nonprofits out there quite often it's
just a way to get tax-free money if you
look at the salaries they pay themselves
you look at where the money goes so many
Charities have these kind of problems
and so it's obviously humiliating when
someone who has a YouTube show and
YouTube is still looked down upon by
many people who are still in the
mainstream even though it's where most
people go to get content nowadays when
he can just go to Africa and do it it it
shames them they should be embarrassed
uh but the fact that this is viewed as
racist like it's racist if you don't
provide people with water we're seeing
that in Gaza right now it's racist if
people don't have water but it's racist
if you give them water I'm starting to
think that everything is racist Dave I
don't know if I'm wrong C J um according
to my paperwork here you are
black I I think so I well according to
Joe Biden no but that's neither here nor
there I think what's crazy about this
entire story here is that the people
that are complaining you have the Kenyan
politician obviously is just embarrassed
and you have a woman who lives in
Cambridge Massachusetts who for the
record anyone who's been there that's
the home of Harvard University not
necessarily a blue collar neighborhood
there but you know who isn't complaining
the Kenyan children who now have access
to fresh water like this is actually the
most insane story again like I I I agree
I can't believe that we are even talking
about this or have to talk about this
but this always happens he goes out he
does good and then people accuse him of
being of of of over like abusing is
privilege so helping people in need is
abusing isn't that what they want isn't
this like some form of reparation like
it's insanity and as you said though
like no good deed goes un punished these
days